today we're going to talk about how to
grow
very thick
hair now to be totally 100 transparent i
do sell
products that help stimulate hair growth
as well as a shampoo and conditioner
that also supports the growth of hair
but i am 100
non-biased of my own products and that's
100
sarcasm
all right now that i got that out of the
way let's dive right into the video all
right the first thing i want to talk
about is iron okay what is iron iron is
a mineral
that is involved in building up your
hemoglobin okay that's the stuff that
helps you carry oxygen
through your blood
and if you don't have hemoglobin in the
scalp
you're not going to have oxygen
for the little roots of the hair
follicles and without iron you're
literally starving
that hair of oxygen so it can grow it
needs oxygen to grow but it's very easy
to get iron especially if you're not a
vegan
just a little red meat a few times a
week will give you plenty of iron but
you can also get iron in eggs and
cheese it's in a lot of different foods
all right
zinc if you're deficient in zinc which a
lot of people are you're going to have a
real
problem growing thick hair the hair is
going to come out very very thin zinc is
involved in hundreds of different
enzymes
especially with making proteins okay and
your hair is protein so without zinc you
don't get good growth of the hair and
you don't get the thickness of the hair
that you really want and the hair will
dry out okay so zinc is very important
here skin
nails things like that um a little red
meat again will give you enough zinc now
there's a condition called telogen
effluvium okay now what is that that is
a condition triggered by
shock or
stress that makes your hair fall out and
become very very thin okay and very very
fragile and that is because of this
thing called stress so if you uh go
through pregnancy for example and you
wonder why your hair is thinning out
well that's why or let's say you have
some emotional stress or a loss of a
loved one or surgery
or an accident
or you over exercise all these things
can raise cortisol then cortisol then
causes you to increase the requirement
of zinc and if you're already deficient
in zinc then you're going to have a
problem with your hair
intelligent effluvian is basically hair
shedding which is temporary
caused by stress now if you consume a
lot of alcohol
or you consume a lot of sugar or for
some reason you get a lot of copper all
these conditions are going to create a
zinc deficiency so just realize that low
zinc creates all sorts of problems with
your hair and there's many different
ways you can become
deficient
and i pointed out quite a few
shellfish are probably the best source
of zinc like oysters but you can also
get in red meat all right the next point
i want to bring up is omega-3 fatty
acids so if you don't like fish or for
some reason you don't like cod liver oil
i don't know why anyone would have the
aversion to i don't know eating cod
liver well because it's so delicious you
could end up having a deficiency of
omega-3 fatty acids now if you have
you know the typical diet that most
americans have you're going to be very
very high in omega 6 fatty acids and
that can create the deficiency of omega
3 fatty acids and that could be the
reason why your hair is becoming very
very thinned but make sure you get
enough salmon or
cod liver oil for your omega-3 fatty
acids plus omega-3 fatty acids are very
anti-inflammatory so if you have
alopecia for example
you have too much inflammation next very
important ingredient to making
thick hair is vitamin d
vitamin d is
just
so important in hair growth it directly
stimulates the growth of hair
and a lot of people are deficient a lot
of people take vitamin d
but they're either not absorbing it
because they don't have the other
cofactors let's say for example they're
deficient in bile and they can't break
it down for some reason or they have
some type of gut issue which they just
you know the gut's not able to absorb it
but vitamin d is very very important try
to get your vitamin d from the sun of
course in the winter you can't do that
vitamin d is really important in the
immune aspects of hair
both inflammation and autoimmunity when
we get to hair because
certain people have an autoimmune
condition that causes the hair to fall
out of their scalp those particular
people
need a lot more vitamin d
than other people
so i'm talking about
40 000 or maybe even 50 000 iu's
per day all right
selenium okay selenium
very important in
thyroid health and converting t4 to t3
and as you may already know if you have
a slow thyroid that alone can stop your
ability to grow hair but selenium is a
important antioxidant for the hair to
reduce inflammation
to definitely counter
alopecia and um also dandruff have you
heard of cells in blue that's a selenium
sulfate compound if i'm not mistaken
and
that actually inhibits the fungus that
causes dandruff so selenium is very
important in different aspects of of
hair and scalp but just taking one
brazil nut can give you enough selenium
okay
all right so then we have biotin so
biotin is essential to enhance the
keratin the type of protein that hair is
made out of and the strength of it
biotin is essential for that and your
own microbiome makes
biotin and so this is why when someone
gets an antibiotic they could end up
with thinning of the hair and they're
wondering why because you just wiped out
your good bacteria that's supposed to
make that specific type of b vitamin but
a lot of people experience great results
with biotin for thickening of the hair
so that's another
element that i wanted to bring up all
right the next one is low
folate um i would never recommend taking
folic acid which is the synthetic
version of folate always take folate or
the active form of folate there's
different forms but you want to get a
natural form but folate is a co-factor
for many different proteins in the body
including
hair
skin
and your nails so without folate you're
going to have a hard time
um
fully developing the protein necessary
in certain parts of your body but it's
very easy to get folate to start
consuming salads on a regular basis and
you'll definitely have enough folate
it's in the dark leafy greens all right
vitamin c essential for collagen
and your hair is part collagen so
vitamin c is very very necessary of
course i would never recommend the
synthetic version of vitamin c
get a natural version or just get it
from the food
you can get plenty of vitamin c from
sauerkraut from cabbage
from
berries
from
bell peppers
and pretty much
almost every single vegetable having
enough vitamin c makes the collagen very
very strong and the other thing i want
to bring up about the hair especially if
you have thinned hair and you want to
thicken it is if you start the ketogenic
diet and you don't consume enough
protein
let's say you're not consuming like real
food protein you're doing protein
powders which i don't recommend
i recommend increasing the amount of
eggs you eat
high quality grass-fed
meats
and that can actually help you
develop thickened hair right off the bat
so just don't forget about protein and
consuming enough protein the other
symptom you're going to notice if you
don't have enough protein is you're
going to feel
tired and lethargic all right i want to
give you some other tips one is
seek help the cool thing about sea kelp
for hair is it has the trace minerals it
has iodine selenium zinc
manganese but it also has the amino
acids
as well as the b vitamins so it's a
really good
product for hair growth the other point
i'm gonna bring up is over washing your
hair
okay
some people wash their hair way too
frequently and that just dries it out it
takes the oils out
if you use a shampoo that has sulfates
it's going to dissolve the protein in
the hair uh take out the oil
and leave your hair very very damaged so
make sure that you don't over wash your
hair now of course some people are going
to say oh dr berg told me not to shower
again no i didn't say that you can
shower just don't wash your hair every
single day and watch what happens your
hair actually will be much much better
quality it'll be healthier all right the
shampoo that you use
very very very vital i would recommend
using a shampoo without sulfates with a
lot of clean ingredients that don't have
side effects but the main thing is get a
sulfate free shampoo
now i'd also recommend getting a really
good conditioner something that has
clean ingredients as well as the
essential oils
and the fats needed that can go into the
hair and revive your hair all right the
water that you use when you take a
shower and so if it has like city water
where you're having the fluoride and the
chlorine
not good just get a filter
um i will put some recommendations down
below if you can't find one
but i'm also having a difficult time
finding the shower head it's easy to
find the whole house filters but the
shower head specifically for fluoride is
a tough one but
i'll put a link down below the one that
i found
but when you don't have the fluoride and
the chlorine boy does it make your hair
shine just without using these chemicals
just using good water it's quite amazing
all right the coloring if you dye your
hair just find someone that can help you
use
a non-toxic dye there are a lot of
chemicals to make your hair a certain
color so find something
that is more natural even though it
costs more it's going to be important in
the long run
all right the next point i'm going to
bring up is this thing called stress
i've seen people go through emotional
losses and literally lose
their hair completely so stress can play
a huge factor and the quality of the
protein being produced in the top of
your skull that is because of high
levels of cortisol cortisol is very
catabolic which means it breaks down
proteins
so do whatever you can
to help reduce stress i have a lot of
videos on that i'll put some down below
last point i want to bring up
is if you're a smoker
smoking not only depletes you have
nutrients but boy does it dry your hair
out it oxidizes the hair it puts a lot
of chemicals in in the hair
you will find that people that are
smokers have
very very um
dried out old looking hair as well as
skin so if you're a smoker do whatever
you can to stop smoking all right so now
that you have
some good information about how to grow
thicker hair
you may want to check out my other video
which is very popular on hair growth
it's right here check it out